[Música]
quando o filho da gente pergunta pra
gente assim mamãe por que está indo
trabalhar o que ele tá perguntando na
verdade é o que é tão incrível
sensacional demais que você me deixa em
casa eo bichinho ele carregou isso desde
pequenininho porque nunca acha que já
fazer algo na época ele quer saber o que
é tão incrível que você não tá comigo e
paz nem quando a gente não sabe a
resposta
e você pára pra pensar kara filho não
tem nada realmente tão incrível então
demais então sensacional que me faça
deixar você que é que acontece
como é que vai trabalhar um conflito ou
você não vai
nós temos 69 milhões de mães no brasil
ea cada 10 mulheres 4 não retornam após
a licença-maternidade sabiam disso é
bastante gente né
e são variados motivos e essa confusão
entre o prato que você tem que
equilibrar como mãe e o prato que você
tem que lidar com um profissional
a gente vai dizer sem a 0 em algum
momento disseram para o mundo que uma
mãe não é capaz de equilibrar a sua vida
profissional da sua vida materna
isso aconteceu a gente acreditou e aí a
gente não foi
e aí a gente não vai e aí a gente deixa
de acreditar em mais e é existe então é
é meu trabalho hoje o que eu faço a
gente acelera mães empreendedoras mães
que estão perdidos na sua carreira ou
acelera mães que não vai pra onde elas
vão a gente dá voz a que vocês falam que
vocês quiserem eu não gosto de ficar o
tempo inteiro com meu filho
isso dói gente ouve também não conta não
gosto eu amo meu filho mas chega uma
hora que eu preciso rodar o pratinho
preciso transar precisa arrumar precisa
sair com meu marido preciso
o momento de trabalhar e tudo bem
então a gente pode falar o que a gente
quiser pra que demitir dos cenários para
que você escolha o que vocês querem
voltar pro mercado você quer empreender
é eu vou atrás de grandes corporações né
porque eu acredito que a grande mudança
é quando a gente está sozinha no mundo
menor do que os grandes empresas a gente
demora pra ajudar o maior número de
meios possíveis então pega uma pastinha
batula falou irmão precisa de uma ajuda
isso você é grande ou pequena
vamos lá e aí onde eu fiz todo o meu pit
propósito as mães os números 78% das
mulheres começam a empreender após a
maternidade raseira quando acabei de
falar uma [ __ ] emprego caiu pra mim eu
não acredito em nada do que estou
falando
eu não acredito em você eu nunca disse
nada mais que você representa
eu não acredito nessas mulheres eu não
acredito que nenhuma idéia dessa vai
ficar de pé
eu respirei e aí essa hora ele falou eu
eu falei do eu eu fiquei emocionada
falou
só que não era isso que queria te falar
eu queria falar o seguinte é não sou eu
não acredito
seu marido também provavelmente não
acreditou primeira vez em solo nem a sua
família nem o mercado todo nem as
empresas nem a mídia nem ninguém
por que é tão difícil ser mãe é tão
difícil entender que a gente na nossa
minúscula capacidade de má fama de homem
não consegue entender como é que vocês
conseguiram rodar as duas coisas
então quando você me traz esse espelho
dói em mim e aí eu trato mal e outra
coisa você está errada porque você tá
falando só para mães a verdadeira
mudança vai quando você pode pegar pra
convertido
eu pegava convertido eu falar alto não
ficar feliz e aplaudia estava vazando
mas a mudança é falar o homem falava
'não mãe para os jovens
e aí eu aprendi uma coisa que foi
interessante esse dia que eu falei cara
minha platéia tem que ter um homem tem
que ter mulheres em que todo mundo
quando na aldeia todo mundo sabe que uma
índia grávida
é todo mundo interessado naquilo todo
mundo se ajuda o pajé as crianças e
adolescentes os pais não pais mãe
natureza
todo mundo se movimenta ao redor daquela
mãe porque eles acreditam que o furo o
fruto daquela daquela daquele ventre
ele vai nascer ele vai para onde ela vai
e aquela criança tem que crescer não tem
ela que vai caçar ela que vai defender a
tribo né ela que vai fazer as próximas
crianças para o mundo e como a gente faz
quando é quando a mulher chega na regata
ela está grávida como a aldeia se
movimenta na boca ea mulher fica como eu
falo falo quarta-feira botão conferência
não sei onde o internacional chileno
falou agora e aí eu recebi relatos de
gente que amarra a barriga até o quinto
mês
a gente está chorando no banheiro na
privada semana foi levantado em paz a
cara passa maquiagem depois a gente se
fala agora dá pelo fato da tarde vai ter
que continuar a segurar a onda então
assim o meu convite quando eu eu trago o
empreendedorismo a maternidade é esse
que dá pra fazer mas não dá pra fazer
sozinha não dá não dá não é possível
pensar grande
sozinho só é possível pensar grande
de maneira colaborativa usem a rede de
apoio usem os homens e as mulheres eram
mais fale mais pra eles peçam mais ajuda
usem redes de apoio e empreender é a
mesma coisa
descobriu que uma rede aí eu fui pro
mercado tentar entender como eu poderia
ajudar mais essas mães e 99% dar toda a
riqueza do estado de são paulo é feito
de micro e pequenas empresas
somos nós que fazemos a diferença e 47%
das empresas hoje micro e pequenas
empresas do país são liderados por
mulheres 67 milhões e milhões de
mulheres grupo de mães que falaram 20
milhões são solteiras como elas rodam
isso tudo gente com outras mulheres às
vezes com outros homens com um porta com
quem ajuda então empreender
é possível é difícil é complexo e é
solitário
mas não precisa ser é continuar com o
difícil vai continuar complexa mas não
precisa mais ser solitário eu trabalho
com startup então todos os palcos que eu
ia ajudar a desfazer o apetite deles a
validar relógio acresceram masculinas
jovens né e momentos com tecnologia e aí
um palco materno hoje ele só é possível
porque também é colaborativo
elas podem não porque elas disseram que
elas podem porque a gente cresce 33% ao
ano 2010 foi o primeiro ano que as
mulheres compram um milhão a mais que os
homens e commerce um cartão de crédito
delas
então vamos para o número vamos para o
fato um argumento o dinheiro porque
empreender é assim é selva e é selva e
nós vamos passar juntos só é possível
pensar grande
de forma colaborativa e outra coisa
falou de empreendedorismo e de nada a
gente tem duas coisas que é importante o
empreendedorismo equipe e capacidade de
execução
o facebook foi o primeiro a rede social
que existiu
o google foi o primeiro buscador não
porque eles estão aí os outros estão com
capacidade de execução equipe a passar
de execução equipe quando leva as
empresas a rodada de investimento
a primeira pergunta agora faz é com a
sua equipe e eu descansei de entrar em a
união ea primeira pergunta que me fazem
essa maria e seu sócio
mas aí eu falei assim não é meu sócio -
quatro mulheres
vamos continuar a conversa é então assim
o que eu peço a vocês é que a gente
trabalhe e os homens
a gente precisa deles do pragmatismo
deles da capacidade de guerra deles e da
nossa visão e juntos cara é uma mistura
então meu convite nesses últimos minutos
aí é que tem na mão pro lado tem na mão
para o outro
percebam que a mulher precisa uma
fragilidade falem a verdade mentiras
confortáveis não me interessa não
deveria interessar vocês e cause um real
impacto no mundo ele que a gente tem
dois grandes marcas importantes na vida
um é quando a gente nas e outra quando a
gente sabe pelo que nasceu e eu tive a
chance da minha vida saber pelo que eu
nasci e foi pra mostrar que tem mulher
no palco é boa e produtiva e banheiro
dinheiro gera emprego e é isso aí
brigada ram
[Aplausos]